do you want me to answer that or do you  already know the answer we asked ryan to  answer the common questions people also  ask when googling his name  is ryan reynolds bert reynolds son i  have no relation to burt reynolds uh  in any way shape or form unless he's  like a distant  uncle or great uncle i don't i do  however love bird reynolds  i always have always will  [Music]  are sandra buck and ryan reynolds still  friends  oh that is we are friends yeah i'm lucky  to count sandra as a very good friend  did keanu reeves and sandra bullock date  wow i do not know actually  i don't think so maybe i don't know  come on google google should know that  for more from ryan and the cast off free  guy visit collider.com